القضاء العراقي يصدر حكما باعدام قاتل
الخبير الامني هشام الهاشمي بعد جدل
ومحاولات بلغت 10 مرات متتاليه لتاجيل
النطق بالحكم المركز الاعلامي لمجلس
القضاء الاعلى قال في بيان مفصل ان محكمه
جنايات الرصافه اصدرت حكم الاعدام بحق
المتهم احمد حمداوي عويد لارتكابه جريمه
اغتيال الخبير الامني هشام الهاشمي في
السادس من يوليو عام 2020 امام منزله عن
سبق اصرار وترصد وان الحكم ياتي وفق قانون
مكافحه الارهاب رقم 13 لسنه 2005
عمليه اغتيال الهاشمي اثارت ردات فعل
شعبيه وادانات دوليه بسبب ما وصفتها
منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه انها جريمه متعمده
لاسكات صوت الهاشمي المنتقدي لتصرفات
جماعات المواليه لايران توعدت بتصفيته
اللحظات الاخيره للهاشمي كانت مساء السادس
من يوليو كان يهم بالتوجه الى محطه
تلفزيونيه بسيارته الخاصه للحديث عن
انتهاكات الميليشيات وتنفيذ الهجمات
الارهابيه قررت جهه المسلحه تقول الانباء
انها ميليشيا حزب الله العراقي ارسال
مسلحين لقتل الهاشمي امام منزله بمنطقه
زيونه وسط بغداد حاول احد المسلحين فتح
النار على الهاشمي وهو داخل سيارته ففشلت
المحاوله ليشهر مسدسا ويفرغ رصاصاته في
صدر الهاشمي سارع اولاده وبعض الاهالي
لاسعاف الهاشمي ونقله للمستشفى لكن الرجل
لفظ انفاسه الاخيره وفارق الحياه قرب
منزله ومع محاولات جهات سياسيه وحزبيه
التغطيه على حادثه الاغتيال لمده عام كامل
اعلن رئيس الوزراء السابق مصطفى الكاظمي
في يوليو من عام 2021 القبض على قتله
الهاشمي بعد وعود قطعها امام الملا وبث
التلفزيون الرسمي اعترافات المتهم وهو
ضابط برتبه ملازم اول في السادسه
والثلاثين من العمر
الغداره وقف السيده عندي ما اشتغلت بعدين
طلعت المسدس مالتي ورميتها يمكن ارفع له
خمس طلقات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات